so before you went in
uh you were you obviously there's a very
public beef between you and rj
i don't know not no more i was going to
ask you man is a nice guy
yeah we're good now you guys you guys
got past that yeah i mean we got past it
before i went to jail i said i don't
know
i don't know i guess that was the only
thing they could use in my case i don't
know
to make it look like something i guess
how dope was the uh
moment were you in jail when him and
greedo did their show
yeah did you hear about it when you were
in jail i'm the one telling greed how to
do it i told him don't take it
don't take it forward it's not gonna go
nowhere right
make some money off it if you're gonna
do it then they had the show
so yeah was that dope to see like
because that was a i think that's gonna
like
in 10 years 20 years from now that's
going to be one of those moments in la
hip-hop history
yeah that we might not have known how
special it was
but the fact that those two crews were
on stage at the same time
i guess nothing happened it was peaceful
yeah that's like i guess that was like
the first
verses then if you want it was the first
verses if you want to be technical
yeah a hundred percent yeah that's real
what about what greedo uh
do you keep in contact with him right
write him yeah
how's he doing how's his spirits he's
straight i was talking to him in jail i
stopped talking to him because he said i
was getting him in trouble
so i stopped talking to him you guys in
the same jail i i in texas but i don't
know i guess he said he got in trouble
because they knew i don't know they said
they knew that he was in another jail
car or something i don't know
oh [ __ ] i don't know